last time i saw you were in a swanky
hotel in london and here we are
six months later who could possibly have
known what was going to happen
has your life changed in that time oh
it's dramatic that's for sure
had i pitched you a picture of our
future
in this last six months we would have
both laughed it off as a science fiction
movie
and now we're we're having to meet via
zoom
last time we spoke you said uh that you
weren't at a stage to write anything
new certainly as far as an album was
concerned i'm guessing you've had lots
of material over the last six months
yeah hence the two new songs that i'd
added to the record since i did see you
last
now i realized if i was going to write a
topical record and then walk into the
buzz saw of cobot 19 and the george
floyd
death and you know the world kept going
round there was opportunity to
continue my journey on the writing
talk to me about the george floyd song
uh god damn those eight long minutes
um lyric painful song
um and with this whole album
i was witness to history and that's my
position i'm not taking sides i'm just
feel like i'm a reporter and
in retrospect when i came up the album
title 2020 was really meant to be
tongue-in-cheek
and there was a rhinestone a cute bumper
sticker and a t-shirt
but as events started to unfold and i
started to really focus on that
writing one thing led to another and i
said no this is now a snapshot of
of my life and the history that i
witnessed
and so whether i i lived it or read it
or watched it
these are the events that unfolded so
when i
in lockdown saw the
videotape that the rest of the world saw
of the death of george floyd i was moved
maybe it's because we were in lockdown
and couldn't go anywhere else or maybe
the quality of the video
and the audio being right there for all
of us to witness
if that didn't move you i just
questioned your
sense of humanity i wonder if it's made
us
more aware of each other during lockdown
i know you talk about
uh me not we and whether we've changed
our attitude
now when we're more we not just me
what do you think we need to do to look
after each other better
well for instance as it pertains to
mental health issues um don't stigmatize
them
and so as we work in our foundation for
example
with the homeless and those who end up
hungry as a you know as typically a
result of that
when the general public don't take the
time to think
they say well he could just go get a job
or she could just
get off feet well sometimes when mental
illness issues come
into play we have to remember that and
not stigmatizing them is a step in the
right direction
so people don't aspire to to have mental
illness they don't aspire to be homeless
or hungry
and and when we realize that these
things are issues that we can control
uh through health care and assistance
uh i.e foundations that provide
food or shelter we as a people will only
be
better for it how has lockdown changed
for you personally though as a family
man have you found that you've been able
to have more time with your wife
and children yeah like everyone else you
know being forced into lockdown and not
having anywhere to run off to
uh gave you more time with yourself
and so for those who survived it
and were able to still have food on the
table and
shelter it was a reset button and some
good things came out of it opportunities
to get in touch with
those around you or with yourself you
know those who lost their jobs or lost
their health or lost their lives they
were affected in a dramatic way and we
can't forget that
in america we've lost 200 000 people and
counting
it's criminal but um
you know so you have to remember that
too this is serious
what do you put that down to we blame we
blame in part
our government for the way that they um
dealt with certain aspects of um
coronavirus
what do you do in the us well it
you know i don't want to just point
fingers of blame
because it seems too easy and
in fairness the needle was moving
wear a mask don't wear a mask travel
don't travel total lock down don't lock
down
and then it got to a place where we're
politicizing a mask
that's wrong that was just that that
is wrong if a mask was going to stop the
spread
if for nothing else then respect of your
neighbor and your friend
you have a little piece of cloth on your
nose it's not a big deal it's not a
great sacrifice
i think wearing a face mask as i greet
presidents prime ministers dictators
kings queens
i don't know somehow i don't see it for
myself i just
i just don't maybe i'll change my mind
this president
long ago forfeited any moral leadership
in this country
he can't stop the violence because for
years he's formatted it
how do you feel about biden i feel good
i feel good you know he's an experienced
man of the world who as our vice
president and a senator from the state
of delaware
has served the country for probably
close to 50 years now
um i've spoken to him recently
and i found him to be engaging and and
on topic and
and caring um so i feel okay about it
he said you spoke to him recently what
about i had done a fundraiser i'd sung a
couple songs on a zoom
um so you know it was that kind of a
simple engagement you know you see him
on television and and
both candidates are doing their thing
they're preaching their gospel
and the american public's got a tough
decision uh
because the future of the country and
its reflection on the world rely on it
how are you gonna feel um if uh we get
four more years of president trump
that's a nice house you've got there was
there anything
available in the neighborhood i was just
just wandering asking for a friend
you know what's your plan for election
night popcorn and watching the telly too
late
i think you should refer to it and i'll
give you a little tip as election
week it's not gonna be a night
uh i think that's becoming more evident
uh
with every day um so get used to
to being here for a while my prediction
is that you don't call a winner that
night
um but where will i be uh yeah i'll be
glued to the
to the tv and and watching
what happens between now and then you
mean it's going to be too close to call
i just don't think everything will be in
we're going to rely on these mail-in
ballots
five states that have never done it
before uh new jersey
is being one of them is going to rely on
that
as an entertainer do you feel the weight
of responsibility weighing heavy on your
shoulders
we're looking to you to to lift the mood
when we can
finally go out again and potentially go
to a rock concert or wherever
i don't know that it's a responsibility
but every artist has the opportunity to
bear witness to history and to record
pages of the lives that we are
collectively living
um you know when i wrote do what you can
i wrote it simply on an acoustic guitar
and performed it that way
on a little zoom telethon here in new
york and new jersey
but uh i knew how to make it into a
record and the record is big and
optimistic and a
bon jovi kind of an anthem uh and it
brings that sense of optimism
back so what i'm hoping is that in a
year or two from now when i do get to
perform it
people will look back on this moment
remember that coming together
if you can't do what you do you do what
you can and then there will be
kind of that reflective joy looking
back on it you know in our rear view
mirror when you do
your next concert when you do your next
gig you want to do some of
the new stuff which ones will you do you
want to do some of the old stuff
which ones will you do you know the old
ones i'm expected to do
and and i understand that when i'm a fan
of a band i want to hear the hits too
you know the hits are what got us there
but i'm just adding
to that arsenal you know and the new
record i would hope to play as many
songs as i possibly could
i'm as excited about playing the songs
on 2020
as i would be to break out the hits last
time we spoke
um you had just organized to see harry
we are very sad to
lose him here in the united kingdom and
he's been getting a pretty rough ride
any thoughts on that well you know who
are we to comment
until you walk in in his shoes he and i
were actually slated to do something
here in new york
that had been postponed and then
rescheduled and now postponed yet again
so who knows if it it'll ever happen at
this point
but it was around veterans my buddy pete
tanzan you may have heard of him uh he
sends his
regards wow just please even knows who i
am
he certainly does and he's still rocking
he's still looking forward to going on
tour with the who
next year in the united states are you
hoping to still be going
when you're pete's age god bless pete
and roger
you know i wish that all of those guys
and jagger and richards
would quit for one reason at least i
would know where the
end zone was i've been chasing them my
whole career
37 years into it they're not slowing
down and they've been at it for
50 plus years i just want to know where
the end zone is so i can take a nap